este es uno de los peligros que afronta
persona en este momento está en poder de
las tropas ucranianas pero solamente
cruzando el río de nípar que está detrás
nuestro están ya las posiciones rusas
por eso los constantes ataques que oímos
permanentemente de artillería también se
oyen drones y la población obviamente se
siente tranquila en el sentido de que
las tropas ucranianas están en el
control no tienen a los rusos caminando
por la calle esperando que vengan a sus
casas pero al mismo tiempo lo sienten
muy cerca y por eso El clamor general es
que quieren la paz que que sus hombres
estén bien que puedan terminar esta
guerra con Victoria para Ucrania todos
dicen somos ucranianos sin embargo el
temor aquí es bastante grande y otro
temor que se suma es el de personas
cercanas o colaboradoras
Rusia hay o que colaboraron con ellos en
su momento y que se quedaron en la
ciudad ese es otro factor de temor de la
población y también de las tropas
ucranianas y por eso también tienen el
control de seguridad y de acceso a la
ciudad bastante limitado como se ve
también en los retenes a la entrada de
la ciudad Así que este río atrás nuestro
es uno es un elemento de protección pero
también de inseguridad porque atrás
están los rusos